laney burch used to live her life to the
full
now she's in so much pain she can barely
walk
relying on a cocktail of medication my
daily dose of tablets
for pain relief for my hands the
autoimmune disorder has caused arthritis
four years ago she had a procedure to
help cure her mild incontinence
she had a plastic mesh implant fitted
like this one
designed to support her pelvic floor
muscles like a sling
but the mesh eroded and sliced into her
bladder
causing chronic pain at the worst point
the first when it was when my
all information started that was when i
was
really really down plus the pain not
being able to walk not always being able
to get to the toilet on time
it was just it was horrendous and i
didn't want to be here
and i do now and it upsets me because
that's how i went
i don't want to leave my kids in the six
years that i've been investigating mesh
one of the biggest
issues has been a lack of evidence
showing the risks of the procedure
complications weren't recorded or women
have simply been
ignored that's why a scathing review
led by baroness cumberland last year
called for an audit to take place
to go back and question women who've had
the procedure
but that still hasn't happened
campaigners say such an audit is vital
to show the true scale of the problem
you're actually looking at real women
and real outcomes
so if you took a sample of women from
2010 which is what baroness cumberland
has called for in her report
if you went back to every single woman
that's had a mesh and as to how she's
doing now 11 years later
that is real world evidence and we need
that
because all of these women are missing
so far um from the data
so so many women are going under the
radar there's a massive black hole
of women suffering an audit was one of
several recommendations put forward by
an independent committee
led by baroness cumberlage it said mesh
and the drugs primidos and sodium
vaporate caused
avoidable harm to women a year on and
the issues are still being raised in
parliament
i do not believe that you can
reintroduce mesh without fully informed
consent and you can
only have fully informed consent if
patients are
fully aware of all of the risks and you
can only be fully aware of
all of the risks if all of the data is
collected
and recorded accurately the government
says it's working to implement
five of the reports nine recommendations
and is considering the others
too late fellaini who says her life has
been destroyed by a quick fix procedure
she wishes she'd never had charlotte
lomas sky news